dang the last chance to see the ru
garbage live show is upon us it's to mix
of stand up comedy plus we play the
little a with the crowd yeah the last
shows of the year are December 14th in
Washington DC at the Howard Theater get
the homies get the Boos let's see you
there then we're doing uh two On's
already sold out in Philadelphia at the
Filmore limited tickets left for the
second show at the Filmore that will
sell out let's get those tickets let's
party baby scoop them up love you
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find it
if they grw up to be classy to just a
big old piece of trash trash trash trash
I'm your host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day today we're out back here
at toies in a new edition we're in full
Christmas swing here caught me with the
mistletoe coming out of the shower hit
me with a shocker Jesus okay all right
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he is an international businessman with
ties to East German television that's
what he keeps telling me give it up for
KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate you subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are T cook it then
obviously the I ain't got to tell nobody
in his room the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com
garbage gang get over there it's a
goddamn party and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the old magic man makes us all look good
works the ones the twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the te's and he
dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone MCC
scruffs Toby McMullen everybody what up
boys what up pal we got Don stavi in the
building baby the [__] kids here look
out I ran into this guy out in a story
with a couple of goons all wearing head
to toe sweatsuits real nice we were
couple of apps for the table and stop no
it was like a super producer Meetup we
had your we had your boy we had eldis we
had uh sea of uh guard
dog yeah you told me about we had three
people who were you know who are
responsible for millions of downloads a
week and it's just three [__] it's
just three it's three guys who
three just [__] morons and sweatpants
and it's like so many people rely on
these [__] for their
entertainment and it could go wrong at
any moment I really we were walking back
I was like wow that was crazy you guys
all should have meet up at the same time
you should be like you know like the
tops EST state of course yeah you got
got to take separate flights and [__]
like that meanwhile you're standing on a
street in a story you trying to break a
$5
bill gang the long hair ain't lying cuz
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today the kid
does what we call in the business
numbers he does a lot of numbies he sure
does moves a lot of tickets gets a lot
of views and he's got a brand new
Netflix special out right now entitled
fat Rascal give it up for the one the
only stavos hus everybody there he is
[__] kid you [__] are real
broadcast H look at this [__] more at 10
that's [__] two and a half straight
minutes just introduction high energy
that's [__] insane I love this dude
yeah this you guys start the show so
that if you showed this episode to like
a scile old family member they would buy
that you're like a radio yeah exactly if
they heard that they'd be like oh he's
doing good Henry's on the radio he's a
newsman I my [__] podcast starts like
what's up um your leg up on the armrest
your grundle show you are getting you
are getting real relaxed over there
what's up guys I he's just like eating
grapes the one day just like yeah we got
my friend over here he's [__] cool
what's up dude what's going on what is
the uh what's the budget on the
sweatsuits these days how many you
holding control is it it really is out
of control but no one wears them quite
like it pull off that's the thing I do
feel like it's a it's the kind of
investment I have to make sure you know
what I mean like one you called it an
investment you have to do it it's a
goddamn write off it's a write off I
wear it to podcast I wear it to perform
uh uh no dude it's like when you're fat
as [__] right you really boys take some
notes sing it
sister fellas get the notepads out um
wipe the ketchup off them first and then
take a little take some notes you really
I've been a classic in when it gets cold
track suits when it's warm Hawaiian
shirt that's easy peasy for a big those
are the two there are two that's the two
types of clothing that look better 2x to
4X yes everything else looks horrible
you're not wow you've done your research
come on dude a guy r a [__] skinny
guy running around in a Hawaiian shirt
it's like I hate it I hate it when those
when those got real poppy with the
skinny guys God damn it I had just
started kicking them too yeah yeah yeah
and then the same thing with a sweatsuit
sure it's like unless you are on a
soccer team and you on like an like a
Indian Run for the team it's like you're
not allowed to wear a tracksuit that's
fully how I feel I AG it goes from like
too comfortable to elegant like you look
like you look it's it's part of who you
are I feel nice I feel nice and then you
know this is a nice Middle Ground a nice
little nice came looking nice today nice
no tea right what's that no tea yeah
what do you mean I can see his belly
butt I let the titties hang for sure cuz
they were giving me let them breathe
they were giving me [__] uh cuz I got a
couple uh car heart sweatshirts and they
are a nice a little cover up too for the
big guy but you got to rock them with no
tea the sweatshirt he's ra dog in a
hoodie which is dangerous territory
there that's a lot of you could lift the
breast up and just Avalanche of sweat
come up under that that's where you're a
little in trouble I would it doesn't
feel comfortable with the T-shirt though
and I can't do the white that's an error
with t-shirt that's a t-shirt error
that's not a sweatshirt error need a in
your corner you need more comfy t-shirts
buddy do you do the tank tops oh I'm a
big tank guy are you I'm W yeah a big
tank guy I never know what to do with
the bottom of them cuz they're too
they're they're like it's like a like
the rest of the condom down there cuz I
can't you know what I mean they go a
little long yeah and I can't tuck them
you can't tuck tuck them no that's a
power pulls it down can I be honest I
would really respect if you tucked it
but you would have to go very short
shorts yes you'd have to have there is a
little you can walk the line of just
athletic enough fat guy but I feel like
you said goodbye to that years ago while
ago I stood at the pier and watch watch
can still pull off like old linebacker
Vibes like he used to be in shap he
still he still got a good frame I have
weirdly large calves you know so it's
like if I'm wearing short shorts and the
calves are glistening I can kind of pull
it off a little bit the legs do depend
on it a lot ex yeah yeah yeah but I'm
I'm much it we're talking like we're
talking like you know JV football coach
five we're talking like you know like
not gym teacher kind of you know teaches
one health class no one leaves with any
information that semester that's kind of
the look if you're going if you're tuck
in the tank honestly you would need a
whistle and a cap an unbranded cap and
then you're good unbranded you can't say
anything on it it's got to be just plain
navy blue yeah get a clipboard you'll be
all right cuz gandini hit a certain
point in Sopranos where his belly was
like perfect and it looked the shirt
looked good tucked in and the belt was
just slightly on that angle looking down
it was like if he lowered his sunglasses
that's what the belt looked like no I
know we're in the same position where
our fitness goals are slightly less fat
guys than us it's like less fat not in
shape guys I mean if you're quoting
galenia at any point for a body that's
not great yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
like in in Foley's wildest imagination
get there it's it's season one Tony Su
season pilot the P skinny Min the pilot
he a good look the pilot is like oh my
God running he looks awesome yeah give
me season four I'd be happy four yeah
I'd probably go three just if we're
really shooting if we're really shooting
for the
stars and I'm at season I'm at season
I'm actually I'm at like you just had a
big dinner on his balcony in Italy and
he ain't waking up from it right now I'm
I'm past that I'm that's where I'm at
I'm trying to make it through these last
uh December once I'm done this promo run
if I if I make it out um then it's like
you know we're going to try and get sh
it a little try and get try and get it
back try and get to season three tighten
it up a little yeah that is what that is
how fat you it's funny that's we've
discovered a new scale of fatness is
when you're of seas of Gand I'm GNA
[__] put up a poster and like I'm
going to track my weight loss journey
through am I season one am I season you
know if I I'm at season 4 episode three
right now I at where he's getting where
he just killed Ralph hey look good yeah
yeah
that is a be that a place to be for sure
I'm at another this is a new I realized
I'm at a different um level of fatness
now where it's like I'm too fat to post
black and white pictures of myself
because people will assume the worst has
happened oh
[__] if you see if you see a black and
white like I get people are like oh what
I should have said something like that's
I just talked to him a half an hour ago
he was at dinner yeah so no black and
white photography for I got I'm PBS away
from sepia tone yeah he might he might
as well be on the back window of an
Escalade something like R st yeah angel
wings coming out of your head mhm God we
got to get it together but you know you
you boys know you you've tasted the
Finer Things and it's tough it's tough
to bounce back dude I'm an appetizer guy
abolutely like a cold Seafood Tower I'll
tell you that too shabby the problem is
I like to taste so I'm like I see the
apps and like and then you go you have
like one or two you're sitting there
with four or five people you have one or
you have two in mind oh we'll do this
and then that and then someone goes and
that and do I have doing that might as
well get that and you're like [__] Kippy
kippy's come up with a the have new
Theory let's hear it I am I think we I
think we should get rid of the main
course just do all apps you go out five
five people drinks order eight apps and
then if you still want more order order
two more apps this you're just you're
describing family style eating this is
the this is the standard in Europe it's
the different of the dishes though it's
the difference of the dish the
appetizers are always the best thing you
have you think you invented Tois is what
just happened yeah
but Olaf this is how [__] white trash
you are this that you instead of bread
we press it down real fine and put
Garlic on it five different types of
chicken wings is to this I'll do five
medium five five miles five of the
homicides
no but no no I'm with you and I totally
that is how to eat but dude because if
you overe eat on the apps which we do um
uh you're there and it's like then they
drop like a steak and I'm like I feel
like I'm forced to eat this and I'm
sweating I walk away I my stomach hurts
and by the way you get you get a couple
main courses yes and you split them up
love it but no one does that cuz when
you're ordering you're going I want my
steak I want my you got to break
yourself of that oh that's impossible
stop me I'm man you only really want two
bites of the steak that's all I want
it's what I'm saying dude you get the
nice you get a riy I got no one's taking
the fat cap that's mine get the don't
even dream about it okay but I'll slice
up the rest sure I'll slice up some nice
take some mashed potatoes throw them
yeah try this try that that's how that
is always how that's how you gotp when
we go with the group we if we do we like
hold on just for reference we came up
with this theory in a margarita
Ville when you were it was a flagship
location it was a
flagship but the service was so slow
that after we ate out all the appetizer
like I can get the [__] out of here
let's wrap it up I had three drinks I
had the I tasted all the apps [__]
rocking that feels horrible when the
when there's a huge gap I was dreading
the food dude it's brutal we ate it yeah
of course of course I already PA don't
need like imagine imagine like that's
that's like pausing getting a prostitute
it's like imagine if she sucked you off
and then was like I'm going to go chill
for a half hour and you had time to
think about it you to think about it you
be like your dick gets soft yeah it's
like letting your dick get soft in the
middle of buying you're like I need to
go to church like that's what that Gap
you can't have the Gap the main course
has to hit in a perfect world you did
the last I would even say I like a
little overlap cuz sometimes over an
appetizer has a sauce that I'm like may
I want to maybe I want to dip my steak
in this [__] feel like a fat guy when
you grab that ramkin off off the empty
slap the [__] waiter's hands when he
tries to get the sauce away like no no I
will be keeping this it's just shrimp
tails sir don't you worry about that I'm
making a I'm making my own broth I'm
saving this bar I'm saving this barbecue
sauce for my dessert sir please get your
hands off it I have a crem boule coming
dude that that actually happened to us
in Greece the first day that we were
there we we ate at this place uh and
they brought over a bunch of prawns but
they like tableside serviced it so they
chopped the heads off pulled them out of
the shells and put them on the thing
then the guy takes The Cutting Board
away I'm like whoa whoa where you going
with those he's like you want the heads
I was like yeah I want the [__] heads
Christ suck those things dry you kidding
me these were already grilled and they
took they were already grilled they
brought them out and then they and they
they took the heads off and the tails
off and then you know plated them with
the two big spoons I love that when they
had the two big spoons can I ask you
something when did you pick up prawns
when did you start calling shrimp prawns
I know for a fact growing up you didn't
call them prom no never but these are
the bigger ones he was eating chest
pieces
oh I'll take two more Bishops
please hey K me will you that's
interesting yeah started eating Lincoln
Logs you learning prawns just is such a
I mean they're they're different than
shrimp they're bigger I think
Australians just call no no they're
bigger I don't know about that no I'm
telling you they're they're they're
they're bigger cuz I I started getting
them uh at K clus in in aor okay I still
think called shrimp yeah yeah yeah but
there's got to be some sort of
difference I would I really don't think
there is uh shrimp have one pair of legs
that include claws at the end but prawns
have three pairs with claws oh look at
that stay corrected I mean Foley had no
idea the case but as a man I will say I
am wrong mine had wheels on them I was
in a
wheelchair that's all right if you go
out to eat with your you know who's like
if you walk going out to eat going out
to eat with your your boy who you going
out with I have a yeah crew definitely
you know eldis who you guys super
producer Bo are you doing dinner on the
road after the show you will you go hit
a nice spot or you getting catering sent
to the yeah it's tough now I'm like this
last run has been a like on show kind of
theater run which is cool but um I have
I've been trying to be a little less
little less [__] but we you know when
we when we were in Baltimore I had a big
a big run of shows in Baltimore congrats
by the way yeah that was crazy that was
crazy um and it was you know my hometown
so I have like a couple of my you know
my best friends my family whatever the
day before everybody that and everybody
that like I have eldis I have my buddy
Ben who uh directed the special uh Ben
O'Brien and my friend Christina who kind
of just does like logistic stuff and
these are like people I've known for Ben
is the newest friend and I've known him
15 years you know like respect stav
sticking with the crew No New Friends
with absolutely making sure nobody's
wearing absolutely yeah yeah I know I
can trust them to launder money for me I
know they'll take a gun charge if we
get you're at the border you know how
you know you knew this is a possibility
eldis call your wife tell her you're see
her in seven years need a Ray Lewis in
your corner absolutely you you are the
only comic I could see sending envelopes
of money to your friend's family
absolutely it's like in a pot out front
of the house she gets some money what do
you want yeah yes well take care of
her we make her the like on page we we
get a couple noow producing j a couple
no show clip editing
jobs she's sitting in a lawn chair down
in front of a theater show
smoking where the
sandwiches yeah so we'll just you know
we'll hit uh you we'll we'll just we'll
just really what you described we'll go
crazy on the apps and just like
everybody gets a little something we got
Italian so that's a little less of a
family style situation it's kind of like
everybody gets their own bowl of pasta
but we'll we'll try you know whatever uh
yeah it's it's are you scoping a good
place before cuz like sometimes when
we'll land obviously we're doing the
same thing we're like one nighter in out
and so it's tough especially if you're
in you know Cleveland at 11: p.m. on a
Tuesday it's like you're few and far
between yeah no we'll scope a nice place
out we'll scope it if if we have some
time we'll definitely scope a nice place
out and like really really do it up and
that's the thing it's like there many
app it doesn't [__] matter I just
want to get to the point if the team's
eating we're we're you know if it's like
a designated dinner that's not just
let's get some n not just eating yeah
we're going to dinner it's good yeah
we're going to we're going to get there
for sure we're we're we'll get great way
to put it we're get we'll get the drinks
we'll get the apps whatever the [__] who
cares I just want to get to the point
where whatever Town you're in whatever
the best restaurant is you can say hey
we close at 11: we're going to keep it
open for you
that's got I think you can pick your
spots with that I think you can make it
happen I think you got to I mean that's
the problem with your show being piz in
Toronto stay L for I know so trash
oriented there's not a lot of Michelin
star chefs listening to this we have one
guy who's become a general manager at
applebe yeah yeah tell the cooks to give
us five minutes we'll be here in a
minute we have a bag of loose M sticks
for you guys I'm texting them in order
on the
way Kip this is Ladder shout out to
ladder talking about lad life talking
about term life insurance all right
you're hanging stuff up around a tree
you trip you fall you crack your neck
all of a sudden all them presents are
going back do yourself a favor
straighten the family out with a little
term life insurance and over a ladder
we're talking no doctor's office no
needles none of that [__] up to 3
million in coverage three bills you got
to get approved yeah uh so you don't
have to wait in the doctor's office
you'll fill out you'll fill out a bunch
of paperwork everything can be done from
online from your couch just answer a few
questions about your health and an
application to get started and find out
if you're instantly approved there are
no hidden fees you can cancel at any
time and even get a full refund if you
change your mind in the first 30 days
look at that get your get your stuff in
order baby you're getting older I'm
older he's older you got to tighten up
the Affairs a little bit line it up
ladder even made forbes's best life
insurance 2021 list and it's easy to see
why cuz they're go-getters go to latter
life.com garbage today to see if you're
instantly approved that's ladder l a DD
R life.com garbage one more time get a
pen get a pencil ladder life.com garbage
do it gang yeah K this is AA frames
shout out to Aura best present this
holiday season we're big fans over here
of course we love them got one at the
house uhhuh put it up there gang if you
don't know every frame comes in a
prepackaged gift box with no price tag
on it so it's a perfect gift so you can
save on wrapping paper look at that
they're saving you money right off the J
does come in a nice box I have to say
listen it's a real holiday pleaser I'll
tell you that order Flames displays
photos true to color and automatic
adjust the brightness to suit the light
in the room look at that they're setting
moods and bringing families together
yeah I did one like I've said I got it
uh Denise Denise got one last year for
Christmas she's let's cut the turkey all
the broads got them everybody got them
they gave him to us everybody's got them
and everybody else is getting another
one you get did you get a second home
it's a home run boom put one in a
basement I'll put tasteful Nudes on
there send them I tell you what if it
didn't let you upload new photos I could
say that's one thing but it keeps going
it's a gift that just keeps on changing
man mhm it's crazy hey some of those are
from last year uh listeners can save on
the perfect gift by visiting Ora
frames.com garbage that's Aura a a
frames.com garbage use promo code
garbage to get $30 off their bestselling
frames terms and conditions apply do it
do it yeah I think you get there I think
you get there boys yeah trying baby yeah
um you know what we I shout out to we
had in Chicago Professor Pizza you know
that dude he came he blew great pizza
shout out to Professor P mhm damn unbel
and then I assume you're picking up that
check right that's a work event you're
you got it you got it that would be
funny it's f it would be so funny to be
like yeah you guys want to split this
would be such a I'm like get whatever
you guys want go go crazy you hit him
with the venmo request 1845 yeah yeah it
feels not that is the most like
immigrant [__] that I'm just like I I
would be off I literally would be
offended if somebody tried to pay and it
feels good to pick up the T
when it's just your friends when it's
like and you know you're who are you not
picking up to check with I mean most be
rich also you go down got yeah yeah it's
like if if they're if they're also Rich
then it's like well and it depends how
good a friend you are you know you know
it's like let's say the three of us went
out to dinner I'd pick it up boys sorry
I think I would have to pick it up we
would try cuz there's two of us that
makes more sense of like is true we're
only picking up one if I bring eldis oh
you're bringing an Entourage if I you
know if it's get a reservation if it's
just us then yeah I guess two to one I'd
fight you for it though sure I might
fight I'd fight you for it and I might
uh insist we go if you did beat me I
might insist we go get some dessert that
I pick up or something like that I love
that you know it's funny like I also
like we weren't going to go get
dessert I love how you're like I'd
suggest twist your
arms that that's the thing too money no
money especially waiting tables for so
long when I was a little kid kid you
know my parents they they didn't do they
they they did all right but they didn't
do great but if we went out to dinner
with like my cousins or something my dad
and my uncles would like proper fight
over the chat no no no no no no they
would fight over and then waiting tables
like when I was waiting tables down at
NYU they'd be like I didn't have this I
don't want this I'm not paying for this
like when when did the that culture
change it's very normalized now cuz
you'll go somewhere and they'll be like
how many checks and you're like just he
gets he takes it as a personal offense
well yeah yeah yeah well he get you have
flashbacks of being the guy a waiter who
has to do that yeah it's [__] up I
mean it's just like and you're right
there is something to people who grew up
rich that just like I don't know man
they it's not a very sharing thing
whereas you grow up poor everybody
shares everything you want to be the one
who picks up the chat it's also like
aspire to that some people can't pick
like some people you're like oh I got
like there were so many times where I
had to be covered by a buddy and then
I'm like hey a month later I'm like you
got me at [__] oh
I'll
the shout out to Hans yeah yeah other
way around a fried mushroom I'll tell
you that no I mean and then you know I
had like when I was in Baltimore I had
friends who like let me pay less rent
cuz I was so broke they were like yeah
just live you're a good hang like you
know we wanted to VI stavy brings the
Vibes I really was pay yeah I really got
like a $300 a month Vibe voucher like to
live in Baltimore says that on the invo
yeah and so I I pick up every check I
mean I I like it's I like that's the
best part of that's honestly the best
part of success this year has been like
just picking up every check with my
friends yeah the fighting there's not a
lot of fighting going on with my family
anymore that used to there used to be
like a please now it's not even like a
now everyone's just looking at their
phones when the check comes
out but it's like we wrap this up here
I'd like maybe a slight pretending like
you know the the classic like date thing
where it's like you want your date to at
least like pretend are you sure you
don't want to split pretend you know
what I mean my mom my mom really leaned
into that [__] real quick she put up a
fight for about 6 months now she's
halfway out to the
car ripping a heater she's ordering to
go as the check comes in like no no no
no one more to go please I want to feed
the dog a skirt
steak she just grabbing two live
lobsters out of the tank on her way out
the door Henry did you pay for these I'm
going to set these free these
two I have a i' I have a laundry list of
people who have paid my way and while we
were [__] super poor struggling and
I've I've definitely gotten I've made
some paint where I'm like I've talked to
them I'm like guys I'm never going to be
able to come up with the number that it
would be and cut a check cuz it's just
been it was like a decade but like I I I
went to the Dominican Republic with I
paid for my buddy Hare and I'm like all
right that's I'm going to have to do it
in like events like hey I'll get this
I'll bring you here we'll do this and it
feels nice to finally be like which is
you really got the best of that tra I
mean look they were they shouldn't have
given you that much money they were also
poor the odds of of that paying off was
so low slim to nothing but the fact that
they got what they got for their trouble
was a depressed man on their couch anded
and you got you get to see their smiles
light up at the Dominican Republic It's
just so not fair you were like a [__]
cancer in their home and you and you're
you're also
not it's a reason I get to go to the Dr
I'm like you want my wife's like I don't
want to go like all right I'll take B
yeah yeah yeah you're not standing at
the edge of the pool watching him swim
like like a dad watching little Le look
at him go yeah that's my brother my my
brother is on full scholarship with me
for everything that I put him through
it's nuts course he lets me know yeah
that about covers it you know thinking
about the pizza or something of course
of course well you had the bread
stick yeah I'm getting for my brother
he's like I'm going to start cashing in
some of those IUS now I'm like you and
you can for sure for sure feels good
it's just so weird to be like all right
well here's $500 how you like monetarily
do it you know I know there's no way to
do that you just got to kind of oh I
think you're doing the right way events
gifts covering [__] that comes up you
know I had a buddy that I owed 500 bucks
for for about it was Cassidy wasn't it
no no no that was that was back in
Philly that was that was that was
business he had a joke about it but his
excuse was what you don't need it right
now yeah yeah he was doing
good that's a real dirt Bank what do you
it's just going to sit in your bank
account no my money will sit in my bank
account I ow I owed my buddy from high
school 500 bucks for about 10 years and
I ke every you know I get you I get you
I get you never [__] broke my balls
about it once and then stopped asking
probably seven years ago for it and he
never asked for it I always every time
I'd see him and then I don't know was it
like a year and a half ago I hit him up
I was like hey here's
250y give me another week I'll have the
rest
yeah hey do you have 300 bucks I could
borrow could you break a
100 but no I went over to his house I
was like hey I'm G to stop by I was like
all right stop by went over I pulled the
money out I was like C I was like half
crying he's like I'm like listen you
never broke my balls about this I love
you so much here you go and he's like I
forgot I gave this to you by the way
wait do you have any idea how like what
inflation has done to that $500 like
eight bucks when was it when was this 10
years ago this was yeah no this was
probably 15 years ago 15 years ago Toby
can you check 500 the the I don't need
to do that no no no I'd love to see I'd
love to know this thank you very much Mr
hus I like this I like this narrative
what's the the money equivalent to 15
years ago was What
2007 yeah it's probably you probably owe
him at least like a godamn waron
with inflation you owe him 260 bucks
still God damn
it Maddie give me a couple of weeks I'll
get it to you this [__] guy I thought
he were GNA do something I thought
you're not taking him to the Dr you're
just giving him the money you owe him
without
interest you're giving him less money
all right how about a couple of tickets
to the Philly show over that he man over
just zeroing him out you're [__] rich
now it's always been a dream to
partially pay you back it's been hanging
over my head for years man I didn't even
think about that put that in the t- bill
will
you couple a
t-shirts got to smooth that over give
him some Zippo style
lighters man [__] bastard you got
that pretty goddamn quick I'll tell you
that it's like you had it [__] ready
over there
could have said the internet was down or
something maybe like an idiot in front
of my
friends just a truly diabolical move for
the gentleman from hisor two6 that's
good
that's cond Lisa Rice jamming me up this
guy's a pro broadcaster over here Jesus
Christ no viig on that 500 come on man
[__] pink Mist [__] pig man
down I love you so much man that's so
funny that's
still coming up short the best over just
to zero him out didn't didn't I hit his
mailbox when I backed out of the
driveway too it's probably another 50
bucks I cost Jesus anyway buddy congrats
on the special thanks
Manet thank you thank you thank you yeah
push that out of the way thank you thank
you uh Netflix it's out right now gang
you got to check it out out right now
unbelievable very proud of it uh looks
cool like I said my buddy Ben directed
it uh it's a Paramount in uh in Austin
you know just got a couple it's you know
you know I you come to me you know what
you're going to get you're going to get
fat jokes you're going to get dick jokes
baby you're going to get a little
immigrant humor sprinkled in there
you're going to hear about times my dick
didn't work it's just it's the it's the
it's you know you you get a you some you
know some place you just want to go get
a nice sandwich sure and that's what
this is this is a nice nice chicken
chick cutlet dude fried just nothing
fancy but done well that's my standup
comedy you're not going to have to think
too much
folks we are not trying to make points
we are trying to have a good time having
a fun
out oh godamn all right I have a couple
a couple of questions that we it's been
a minute since you've been on the show
and there's been a couple of uh you know
now constant questions that have come up
that I'd like to pick your brain on
please uh you're getting dressed in the
morning right you're doing socks and
then pants or pants and then socks
H pants and socks I think pants then
socks pants then socks wow okay I think
depos depending on I'm surprised with
that I would say you know why because I
it is a big guy thing and it's the
efficiency of socks and shoes it's the
if we're going to go do that horrible
that horrible bending down the shoes
where I'm in excruciating pain to get my
socks on I am also slipping my shoes on
very fast in that same position I do the
bed I sit like sideways on the bed and
like almost like I'm sitting half Indian
style do one sock and then spin around
and do the other sock and then put the
pants on I sometimes I'll even go sock
same side shoe that's nuts sock same
side shoe that's crazy I've been exper
you've CAU me in an experimental phase
when it comes to socks holy [__] that's
new that's new you know you know uh but
it also depends on what pants I hold on
to short as many fat men do I hold on to
Short shorts deep into the win deep yeah
you know uh deep into the winter so you
know I have decide am I going to do
sweats whatever and the socks kind of di
you know the socks go are paired with
the shoe you're saying the shoes and the
socks are the same they're they live in
the same in the world well there's okay
I'm sorry let me be a little clear
there's two separate things here there
is the shoes and socks the efficiency of
shoes and socks back to back and then
there's also the if I'm wearing
sweatpants or if I'm wearing shorts I'm
wearing sweat if I side was I'm getting
dressed it's sweatpants time then we're
wearing a longer sock if I decide it's
shorts then we're wearing a so I like a
little extra optionality yeah they're
making a lot of game time decisions
that's what sa's he's going up he's he's
going up to the line he's reading it
he's checking the call AUD and he's
[__] Blackjack Blackjack and you know
what else I'm also a big I'm also a big
like uh uh um uh bare feet all the time
guy I'm I'm a slippers guy that's why
it's like socks really are a last minute
they're going on if I'm leaving the
house that's when they're going on can I
say this about the shorts for thinner
people out there if I'm listening and
unless you're like you know you're
taking the Subway or you're working
outside or something like
that I'll tell you you really can push
the shorts because if you're going from
the house to the car and then into
another building it feels nice yeah if
you if you go if you go shorts in a
hoodie shorts in a hoodie you're cozy
enough classic F guy in the winter move
yeah I'll even go if the Sun is hitting
me I'll wear shorts yeah if I'm out when
the sun is out I being out in December
when it's dark out in shorts is wild
that's crazy that's CRA you can't be
doing it it's not that bad it's kind of
I'll be honest with you it's kind of
refreshing yeah it feels good you're
always sweating in the house with the
heat you have to be fat as [__] though
for this to work let's let's reiterate
that yeah you have sure there's no way
also because I think people are just
back to Margaritaville and get some of
this on paper I think people are
conditioning to be like oh fat guy in
shorts I get it like they don't the
connection's already made but if you see
a skinny guy in shorts like that a
crackhead like something went horribly
wrong in this guy's last hour that he's
out here in no that's a good point
that's true what's your slipper
situation cuz it's either like pink
bunny slippers that are now blackened or
pretty nice I would imagine I go I'm uh
I I have a uh a it's it's slides and
it's a specific brand that has a lot of
support uh UFO I don't know if you want
to bleep it out no free no free ads but
uh yeah I like there's just I'll go like
a I'll go like a slipper that's very
cushiony it's a slide kind of thing but
they stay in the house I don't want to
houseo they house shoes yes yes but no
classy guy kind of yeah you have classy
elements yeah just a little support have
you upgraded the the bed and the bedding
and all that stuff you're in a king
right I would assume I am actually so I
have a I have a place in Baltimore a
place here right uh I have not gotten
the king be here because I think I might
move to a better place okay you're going
to wait I'm going to wait you got a king
down in Baltimore have a king did you
when you bought the place did you is it
all like did you put like new furniture
everything in there did you hook it all
up I'm still it's yeah we still drips
and drabs right now drips and drabs kind
of thing but yeah so if we walked in
there now we would think a Hitman
probably not that bad we got a couch we
got a big couch and big ass TV day one
there's no there is no way I am not
having an 89 in television on the floor
leaned up against the wall sure with a
milk crate as an end table yeah yeah but
you know we got a little I still need a
little little more furniture a little
little stuff we're halfway there and
what are what are you sleeping in at
night you all Fresco shorts what do you
I'm a boxer just boxers guy maybe I'll
even let the dick hang a little bit too
maybe I'll go nothing I've I've dabbled
with nothing yeah nothing's all right
fresh off a shower fresh off a shower
nothing is great yeah man I think you
sleep better too I think you might and I
like to I like it cold as well another
another fat guy move i i di sleep with
the AC on now
still cuz it's right above my heater so
it's like a it counteracts it you know
what I mean is it always shower at night
or is it shower in the morning I'll
really let it I'll really let it I have
no straight shower scy no line with it
I'm really if you got stuff to do during
the day you're going to be out and about
probably typically I'll tell you this
typically I will kind of take uh a
honestly right before I have to do [__]
shower like I will especially if I have
to work out I'm not work I'm not waking
up showering them working out what I
mean that's crazy it's probably a more
I'll probably take a shower before I
have to [__] you you're leaving for
theend an event gotcha let's say you got
nothing attend the
gall [__] little open the garbage
podcast you know uh-huh huh okay if
you're not uh uh let's say you you have
two three days you're off the road you
got no pods no nothing you're hanging no
plans and are you will you push it those
two or three days without you hour and
if you're just in the apartment ordering
food you're like I'm just posted up I
can't I certainly can uhhuh but I
probably I don't know that I can go a
full three I was going to ask is both
this now that the Winter's
here I push it a little bit I push it a
little bit you push it a little bit
every it dries out my skin sure that's a
good point it's a lot of effort that's a
good point and there's new studies
coming out saying that you shouldn't be
showering every day and fat guy
quarterly just published the only I love
that I love when people just look at the
studies that you know benefit them you
know what I mean there's a lot of
studies we should be I got my algorithm
yeah start reading the ones on heart
disease will you
yeah yeah there's a lot of studies out
the ones on red meat Foy I say it's all
[__] um yeah you know it'll it
really depends am I up to any stinky
activities sure you know if I'm working
out if I'm especially if you're getting
[__] you got to shower you can't be you
can't be letting that marinate for long
no so I guess push comes to shove I
guess I'm probably say I'm a nighttime
shower guy cuz it just feels nice watch
day feels nice he kind of got me on that
on the road getting getting back from
from the show and before you get in bed
taking a hot one see because I don't
respect the hotel bed I'll just
sometimes pass out filthy yeah that it
does feel better does you just feel like
all right that's over you know
especially after like a meet and greet
you're just sweaty and hot and yeah yeah
you want to wash the animals
off I sanitize after every
hand I'm licking people's
fingers so you'll disrespect the hotel
bed a little bit you don't absolutely
that's the whole point of a hotel yeah
you know and what do you leav in tip
wise at the hotel 20 bucks usually
20 good luck with that I'm out the door
yeah sorry about that I feel bad yeah
exactly I I am [__] it up you will
you know it's you're going to get your
money's worth and I'm not that bad
especially I'm only there a night who
really you know what damage can you
really do yeah especially with the
comforter though I really I just don't
anything I if I sneeze I'm wiping my
hand in that he's crazy yeah that's
brutal stuff if if I'm servicing uh
certain areas of myself that's good the
towels I think is where we all know
most of the disrespect should be to it
doesn't make it there though you got to
have a towel I'll just lay it I think
about that every time I grab a towel and
I'm like how many fat comedians have
jerked the thing at a siner or something
bleach their they're washing them with
high heat it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter spiritually it's still there it's
still there yeah energetically the sins
of that if impressions are on it yeah
that's a sad that towel is tough they
can pull DNA off of that for sure I
don't know man the dirtiest the dirtiest
and nastiest thing in a hotel I think is
that is that towel that they have for
the floor mat you're not using that are
you you just said you blow your nose in
the comforter and you think the thing
meant to [__] step on your feet
that's the thing I hate the most I love
that thing I use that dude I use that
when if I pee if I get out of the shower
it's wet I use that to mop up peeing on
the floor you can tell when Foley's been
in a bathroom on the road cuz there's
about I don't know three lers of urine
okay I'm feeling a lot better A shocking
amount of a shocking amount of your are
you good with that or you missing I'm
not missing at the level you're you're
describing really no no you know maybe a
drip here and there but I mean I'm all
over the road why don't you just piss in
the shower then I do I do and a lot of
times in in a hotel or in an Airbnb I'll
just pee in the shower but not when I'm
in the shower I'll just walk in there
and just pee fascinating yeah I really
that's an insane way to go it feels
great you come back drunk that's one
step above homeless people why I don't
know I don't want to deal with dribbling
and all that stuff kind of dribble are
we talking it's yeah you got you got a
bad stream and a short penis is that
what we're dealing with let's say a
start let's say a double espresso worth
of liquid okay on the floor yeah why I
don't know I don't think he's getting
close enough I'm not sure I don't get
close enough I got to try to see where
I'm going and then lot of it's on the
Dismount it's like when they do those
aerial refuelings like between Jets it
just you know it's the same thing as
that exact same thing a good looking guy
in an F14 time cat that's what I'm
talking about this is interesting
because I you know I'm also a very a
very fat man and I have a small penis
and I'm going to say even and a weak
stream for that matter and I will say I
got a good stream you have a good stream
I have a good stream then this really
feels like just carelessness on you it's
for sure this feels like the kind of and
listen you're an animal it happens I get
it then you you and you know it's there
you know that we're sharing a listen if
he's got his own bathroom what he does
is he does if we're having an Airbnb he
stays on the first floor big man don't
like stairs so if there's a room on the
first floor big man calls it if there's
not I catch a ration of [__] he's got to
go up and or downstairs front of the
house baby I'm head of
security no 's Getting By Me no yeah
everyone's going to slip on your
piss Kippy I got
him you're just laying there in your
seat machine yeah I have to say I'm
feeling a lot better about how I behave
in I thought I was a filthy animal but
what you're describing is deplorable
Behavior yeah no I'm pretty bad so you
really got to get that but I'll put all
my towels in a little pile and stuff
like that and clean up a little bit I'll
throw my trash out yeah okay just don't
touch the [__] I would rather you leave
the towels Wherever not on the floor
yeah but hey what are you going to do
I'm really was just talking about really
[__] up the towels and I try not to
you know WIP sneezing in the comfort is
one of the most despicable things I've
ever heard um but you know to each his
own I suppose I would call I would
really like it if you stopped doing that
just just like I feel some
responsibility told me to be on record
is being heavily against this not
approving so funny are you garbage was
here last night [__] what room would
they out you yeah yeah please yeah just
every time you're in a city please email
me your itinerary so I I will make sure
not to stay
there fair enough fair enough MH I feel
like we should have bring this up but we
were D TBO went into the bathroom after
him recently at an Airbnb and there was
to paper with poop on it on the floor
what the hell is patreon
content it's the floor how did that
happen well it's funny
ass um so how did that happen yeah yeah
W us through
it it's it's careless I thought I
connected right and I didn't it I hit
the rim and and and bounced off and I
didn't see it when I got up why you
shooting three pointers yeah I can
answer that I can answer that SKS
because he's not a fat person cannot
wipe his ass on the toilet this is a
stand up and wipe your ass situation I
have a now now I'm now I have a system
of
bullies I hire three
guys uh before the ymic it was it was a
nightmare it was like an absolute
nightmare but now now I have the reach
and I and I you have long arms yeah I
can I can do my thing a little bit but I
I you know it's still maybe on the way
out fell and it just it just hit the and
bounced but then I didn't realize it and
I did I did one flush first I do one
flush before I go in there sure to wipe
okay and then I forgot to flush again
that's how I got that's how I got that's
how this all came to light because Toby
went in there use a bathroom he's like
[__] somebody didn't flush and then I
went in there and then I saw someone
[__] in the
sink and then I saw the the the the
these the craziest part was that he
stepped on it like I wouldn't see it
like he was trying to hide I didn't I I
thought it was just a regular piece
piece of toilet paper which you would
leave on the floor you wouldn't just
pick that up also yeah I mean I don't
work
there you're just sharing a common space
with your friends um yeah no all of this
behavior is things a four-year-old
child should not he plays it fast and
loose yeah you got to tighten up which
like that's why like we work very well
together it's like yeah you stay on the
first floor and I'll do all of my gr my
GR is in another location got to keep
your distance you can have this Toby's
the collateral damage to get hit to's
got a yeah he's got a you needs some if
Toby has some piss soaked socks every
once in a while he leaves them
everywhere that's the cost of doing
business hey man it's good work if you
can get it
bro tough break big guys sorry about
that uh all right let's get into some
uh I have one more for you then we'll
get to some patreon questions uh you
very rarely get [__] the the the
garbage connoisseur of stavi you know
what I mean he's he's very well versed
in many areas of life AB absolutely what
are you banging with out a tji Fridays
Olive Garden and Applebees oh wow cuz
we've we're very well documented us on
Domino's VP of course Pizza Hut which we
don't have to St up I don't yeah we
don't have to we don't have to open up
Old Wounds but we still should have the
taste test someday maybe when you guys
come on stav's world we'll do an
official taste test people have been
hitting me up about the the remnants of
Pizza Hut that hey there's one there's
one outside of Chicago yeah there's one
25 minutes from my house they still do
the indoor dining you know what I wanted
we wanted to do one of the things we
were talking about trying to do with you
was going finding the last Buffet one of
the buffet that would be the three of us
go that would be beautiful I bet I bet
it still hits absolutely ABS absolutely
boys that's all I'm hanging on to in
life um all right let's see here uh
given to Fridays Friday Olive Garden or
Applebees Andor if not one of those
what's one what you know I was always a
Chili's guy chili my family was always
into Chili's okay um respect and
honestly even Outback Steakhouse whoa um
okay and so toy toyy I know we were not
a big Olive Garden family I can't I'm
speak I can't I think I've been olard
once in my life
Fridays um I didn't really go to eldis
swears by the Jack Daniels Burger to
this day pretty he's a big Jack Daniel I
don't shoot your A1C through a roof yeah
yeah I think that's the only thing I've
had I think I've only gone with him when
we were children Friday's has the best
sampler the best appetizer sampler the
game I when they were doing the like
what was it $5 unlimited or something
$15 unlimited I got I went for that
pretty good I must say um I wait for
thaty good deal is a good deal
we it was some weird thing where it was
like a bunch of f back in Baltimore we
went to go see Planet of the Apes 2 and
then go to TGI Fridays for the unlimited
apps nice um nice little Friday night
right there absolutely um I'm sure that
was filled with the your crew was a
bunch of athletes you know it was a
bunch of weird it was very strange it
was a bunch of like weird alt artist
types that like don't go to tji don't go
to malls at all it was a very strange
crew I was the most like normal person
there without without question they all
got sick afterwards yeah digest system
couldn't handle it um I probably would
go I mean chili the baby the classic
baby back rib okay um but I I what I
thought was classy was I would start
getting the like sirloin I would start
getting steak at Chili's towards the end
of my Chili's days till the end of your
run till the end of my run and uh you
know I they had a corn I sometimes I
would get corn and Fries that was kind
of my combo I they had like a buffalo
popper chicken thing in the mix there
sure I'm ashamed to say I've abandoned
my roots and I've haven't eaten at a
chain like this in quite some time
although where the [__] was I just the
sirloin is where you end up cuz that's
what your that's what dads always got
they always got the steak and exactly
when I was like 14 I was like I'm the
man I'm a man of the house now I deserve
a sirloin from Chili's as
well I got this one can we do three
checks
yeah so yeah okay yeah but I'm uh you
right that's a respectable what would be
the occasion to to hit a Chili's in the
in the Halas family could it just be a
Friday night or Thursday we would maybe
twice a month hit up like uh Chili's
Apple there was an Applebees that opened
at shout out to East Point Mall uh it
took over a um the first place I ever
got a steak was a restaurant called
King's Court in East Point mall that was
like a SE it was like a you it was
almost like a cafeteria style steakouse
where you like pick out
you pick out your [__] sides and [__]
and then you order a steak and they you
know they bring the only thing they
bring you is the steak all the sides and
[__] are there and uh that was a great
experience I had like a [__] T-bone
steak as a child uh cuz I just thought
it looked cool in the cartoons that's
one of the most classic steaks like the
way Pizza is drawn a specific way in
teenage M Ninja Turtles when they draw a
steak in cartoons a T-bone steak because
it looks so a certain way I couldn't
finish any of it that dog on Tom and
Jerry's was always crushing on always
had a fresh one on the grill exactly man
he made it look good he had the chef hat
and everything it was probably Spike
that got me to want Tbone steak Yeah
that and the ham was always really good
too crush ham yes yeah um and then
unfortunately uh big business took over
Corporate America Corporate America uh
crushed King's Court under his heel and
Applebee's took over that space okay and
for the first two years it was actually
pretty good and it was still we would
get steak there cuz we were like well
this must be a steak house like you know
there was a steak house here
before to dry cleaners like and it was
good and then it event falls off they
all fall off they all Come Out Swinging
they're all they're all Towing the
corporate line the manager sces there's
like a regional guy there launching it
he gets out the new guy come and it
[__] sucks he not doing the inventory
they just start slipping they start
cutting back on servers and they're
overworking the servers and then they
get psycho it's crazy yes damn all right
all right I do have to say that is one
thing from like the two things that I
like having money is like the meals have
been upgraded to the point where it's
like I'm not going to uh unless I'm on
the road and I'm in like some horrible
Mall sure I'm not going to uh
Margaritaville like we did last yeah
yeah I'm going to a sick restaurant and
like because I travel so much I'll
[__] I'll just get the most
comfortable possible seat in whatever
I'm on sure you know like that's the two
things that it's like I can't I I really
am enjoying everything else sucks you to
more and the sweatsuits come on yeah
yeah I more I have more of those I still
was a sweatsuit guy even back I made the
money I found the money back in the day
for
sweatsuit yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly who has to pay rent I got the
suits I
got you got the chains glisten by the
way you got a great look today great and
do you have a guy that you're going to
do you have a jeweler Guy where you pick
picking these up yeah I have a I have a
friend who she knows about jewelry stuff
I consult her and I just kind of bought
a couple I'm not a tattoo guy yeah I'll
get a couple chains uh to to Mark a nice
occasion sure I bought this for the
special nice uh and uh I'll probably
rock this for a while and then you know
when I C to celebrate things I'll
probably buy a nice little piece of
jewelry as a you knowy but I don't want
I don't want to overdo it you know get
jmw melt that down exactly yeah yeah
yeah how far away are you from becoming
a ring guy I'll have some rings and I'll
wear them on like I wore a ring I wore a
pinky ring on the special actually check
it out pinky is going to come back I'm
down you oh without question I just am a
very forgetful person so I don't want to
just day-to-day wear Rings cuz I will I
fidget a lot I'll lose them you know
this kind of thing but I'll I'll wear
them out I'll wear them if I'm going to
something if I'm I'm definitely a ring
guy uh and yeah I think I think I want
to get a nice watch next again just a
just a classy move they're nice nice
watches all right but I don't want to
overdo it I want to like I don't know
subtle just a little yeah still too much
money if we're being honest but like not
a crazy amount um and people say that
watches actually hold their value I it
is it is Despicable to me that I know
things like this now you know that part
makes me feel bad I feel like a Trader
just like for a big Trader moment I had
is I I I was in a hotel oh that actually
holds its value well I just say that
that's quite a good investment yeah it
sucks what investments are now depends
on the market really what the [__]
what's gold trading at today dude I had
the moment where I was like GH I'm a
piece of [__] is when I went to a hotel
and like I just knew the sheets were bad
first time in my life I knew the sheets
were bad damn and I couldn't sleep
because the sheets were bad and I was
like I was like who have I become hi
this is Mr hus in the penthouse what's
the thread cap it was brutal they were
bad I was itchy I was like whatever I
was like GH what is this and remember
like I would indoor cat dude I would
just sleep on like bare couches for
years my first on your face my first bed
in New York was just a very used Ikea
pullout couch that I just put in the
corner of a bedroom and slept on like
that was it using a pistachio shell as a
pillow yeah it was I was like GH who the
[__] am I so that was a really brutal
moment where I'm like I know what bad
not only do I know that a sheet is bad
but it bothers me I'm the princess in
the [__] pee over here it sucks
well I I was talking to my buddy about
this it's because you you know you
travel so much you experience all of
this stuff so frequently and high
intensity that you're like yeah I stayed
in I don't know 75 hotel rooms this year
most people don't supposed to stay in 75
hotel rooms in their life of course of
course we could tell if the eggs are
powdered at the at the breakfast which I
like a powdered egg no no no [__] that I
don't mind them they're all right couple
Links of sa you guys are out of your
mind you got to get out out of there you
can't be having Just Breakfast like that
I that's how you feed the crew huh
that's that's Toby's like Toby get the
zip lock out we're having these for
lunch too Cass we're bring Cassidy back
some sausage
links we don't even bring Cassidy with
us we just give him he's up in the
room no I love I do my I have such a bad
pal I have such a white trash garbage
palette I love chicken parm is like my
that would be my meal if I if I was
getting killed it would be like give me
a chicken pal sandwich from Aldos in
Pennsylvania shout out to it yeah um but
I do love the I do like a nice omelette
I like a nice place but like I do just
love the shitty shitty shitty food yeah
my f bar food I love bar food yeah it's
still great for sure but I I don't know
I'll still crush it but it's also like
that is my shitty food is my biggest
problem like my biggest biggest
addiction more than drugs or [__]
anything and so I try and just like eat
a little better but dude I'll go to
Buffalo Wild Wings right now I'll go
right I'll go right the [__] now dud
it's in my blood I'm just trying to I'm
trying to get it is funny cuz it's like
man everything I'm trying to do to
improve my life is just like that is so
much who I was you know what I mean
which just like who the [__] am is even
left if I'm eating salads I'm eating
salads I'm sleeping on nice sheets fraud
who the [__] am I dude it sucks I know
have you had cheese fries in the last
year wow great
question and you got a lot of nerve
asking it I'll tell you that I can't say
that I have I've had plenty of fries but
I haven't had I haven't had cheese fries
yeah okay yeah and that was a main stay
you're right that's like a crabby fry I
would assume right shout out to the crab
fry he likes the dust on it we do that
yeah with some lump with some jumbo lump
on there too not just a
dusting or some crab dip which is
actually kind of a Cheesy fry now that I
think about it crab dips you have very
in that world yeah crab Dip's all right
shout out to nacho m in Canton that's
just good crab dip
good had no trouble plugging them did
you no free ads slipper company don't
give a [__] about na your mama comes up
no no no I got we got to support we got
to support the local Jimmy Seafood has a
nice let's let's get them all dude let's
get them
all good crab omelet at sipping
bite hey shout out to a crab omelet and
the Baltimore Ravens and all their
subsidiaries of course 100% first time I
ever had eggs Benedict Was crab it was
crab eggs benedict it blew my it was at
Silk City in Philly I thought that was
rich people food yes dude I was 20 I
might have been 30 the first time I had
had eggs benedict it was crab when you
see an ex- Benedict and it said and the
number next to it starts with a two it's
a 20 something you're like Jesus
I don't I don't think anybody in my I
don't think anybody in my whole family's
lineage ever had expeditors I swear to
God I swear to God are we all splitting
this yeah everyone gets a bite crazy
yeah there was there was a there was a
place called Tiffany's near our house
that was real real nice and we went
there once and they did like a brunch
thing and the whole thing we all got the
eggs benedict and you only we we all had
one it was didn't even come
yeah we thought we were like oh we
thought we were the kenned one egg it's
that's egg
Benedict trash but we thought they we
they talked about it for a week before
we went and months after we left crazy
we talked about it all through the year
I get it no I get it I mean that's the
same thing when we took my mom like my
mom for her birthday dinner when we
started taking her to real restaurants
she would like fight it at first she'd
be literally she she kept trying to get
us to take her to Panera Bread shout out
to and it was just like no it's your
[__] she's like I don't need this this
is too much you know and it's like just
have a [__] nice dinner for once in
in the last 40 years like please have a
nice dinner sure dude Panera Bread
that's she loves Panera dude do you want
to go to Panera like constantly she's
constantly advocating for Panera
Bread you can eat the bowl the chicken
fona sandwich big hit big hit dude I'll
never forget first time ever went to
Panera Bread I was like still a picky
eater I didn't know anything I'm like
I'm not doing a s I wasn't eating salads
and [__] man I got like it was potato
soup in the bread bowl and the guy's
like are you sure I was like buddy hit
me with it yeah hell yeah dude like
eating Bread soup yeah yeah the broccoli
cheddar you got to do that man come on I
don't think I was eating broccoli at
that point in my life yeah that's when I
was like oh this is healthy yeah yeah
I'm like there's broccoli in here yeah
uh all right let's do uh one or two
questions here then we can we we got to
scad uh this one's just funny this was
from Liam I've never seen my parents
drink
water I don't think I my mom I don't
think I've ever seen my dad it was Diet
Coke or regular Coke right Dad never
drank water never yeah no I that's a
good question we I think Greek people
would do make a big show of drinking
water rub it in your face a little bit
Yeah Yeah like to like on a hot day
there's a lot of gulps and going ah
yeah yeah yeah a lot of that a lot I
just remember water being an almost like
an exclusively summertime drink where
it's like you know you know because it's
a very very Aid climate in gree so I
think they're they're staying they're
staying uh hydrated but it's tough to
drink water in the winter when it's cold
it's like dude it's like drinking razor
blades we were a big Crystal Light
family yeah we were big Crystal Light
family love that I saw my dad drink that
diet root beer beer and every morning as
he's rushing out the door he would take
a cup of coffee pour a little bit out
put cold water in it crush it pour a
little cold water crush it and crush it
and crush it until you got it all down
and then go out the door psychopath he
would just get all his water down in one
kind of with more no but he would do it
just to cool the coffee so he could slam
the Cofe then he would have a massive
panic attack around like 3:00 from
crushing the coffee God damn and they
had to kick them off the caffeine that's
a wild way to drink coffee and water
yeah yeah fun just getting getting the
the drug in you no I love I love the
idea I love the idea of the of people
who just do not have you know that I had
a joke where I was describing like uh uh
like the kinds of PE I don't remember
what the [__] it was like just I was
just describing a type of woman in
Baltimore and one of the things I would
say was like hasn't had water sure it's
been diet you know Diet Pepsi every day
of her life uh Sierra missed Sprite when
she has a cold you know what I mean like
that's the like all the lemon lime soda
was the health that was water ginger ale
ginger ale that has medicinal purposes
it's proven man damn Ginger Sprite or
Sierra Miss cuz to me the Sierra Miss is
the trashier of no we were Sprite for
sure seven up we were big seven up a
little seven Up Seven Up was all right I
feel seven up got to us first I'm older
so seven up and they had an ad campaign
that knocked it out of the park it was a
guy like in the Bahamas wearing like you
know like uh like Tommy Bahamas stuff
and he did the Sprite never seven up
never had it never will the caffeine
they all they pushed the no caffeine and
that dud it was crisp it was crisp
saying you were there at the the
unveiling of seven up you remember that
huh not when it not when it came out but
it was it was pre-s Sprite before Sprite
got big yeah I don't remember a world
preprite I have to be honest for sure
yes because Sprite started creeping into
their Market I think I feel like Sprite
is King right easily yeah that's the
best got got the [__] power of
Coca-Cola
behind
yeah y um all right let's see here this
one's from real bozo is it garbage to
use a lint roller on your face face and
body after haircut instead of just
taking a shower without question that's
crazy it's kind of strange it makes
sense though it's strange that that you
would even it's crazy that the person
who would think to do that would have
access to a lint roller yeah that's kind
of the thing definely stolen that's
what's not adding up here but it's
absolutely I should have able to spell
it that was put back on the Shelf at CVS
on his way out the door yes you're right
he walks in just [__] yeah takes two
sips of a [__] Sprite puts it back
can you get a haircut and then go out
and do your day or do you have to get
right in the shower I haven't been a
haircut guy in so long cuz I went from
bald to growing my hair out triming at
all or I'll do a little I'll do little
trims I got to get right in the shower
after a haircut I cannot [__] I can't
go anywhere itching Foley really flexing
his head of hair with that question I
know one guy who's Let It Go and one guy
who's holding on to it you get haircuts
what are you talking about talking about
when you were a kid you got haircuts
this all CGI dude where do you think all
that patreon money's
going oh [__] you you guys don't sell
your hair after after uh after you get a
cut you should get plugged up dude what
the [__] come on I don't here's my thing
onug Zed up you're plugged up let's get
it going he gets [__] cut I start
getting good looking hairline starts
right here dude that would be [__]
awesome the new podcast are you hot yeah
I would love that you guys should do
that every year you should do some like
some kind of like plastic surgery just
like cuz it's are you garbage and then
by the end of it you should just be like
completely doesn't move face doesn't
move just like blonde hair like
completely sold out it would be that's
the natural AR that is true for the
garbage like a garbage person would what
I'm saying makes sense I got a set of
fake tits yeah yeah I've always said I
would do I one it's it's not a pain
point for me like you don't I don't I
genuinely don't care um I'm just going
to just ride it into the sunset whatever
but I said I would do plugs as long as I
could guarantee and I know obviously we
have friends and people you know
publicly done it um I just don't want I
want them to look good enough to
we cuz no one's going to tell you they
look bad yeah they're going to go oh
looks good and behind your back and go
what the thing is four times a week this
podcast I promise you the thing is we do
live we have we're in a group of like
our friends will tell you if it looks
bad I but I think that's the thing once
it's in it's so permanent people are
just going to be like oh cool I think
you could always take you could always
just shave your [__] or something I
don't know yeah you get them yanked out
they look good these days man who wants
to do that they're looking good these
days they do look great the people that
I know have them look [__] fantastic
I just think it's also very expensive
this year is the year of fley on OIC
next year is the year of you on plugs
all right then we're doing a little chin
filler maybe a little lip you I put the
butt I'll put the dim in yeah slowly we
just got to get you guys looking more
and more like what trash does when they
get money loty couple of cheek cheek
implants Brazilian buttlift let's go I'm
walking around with a dumper I'm going
to go i' I will get plugs when I'm like
60 cuz I want to go I always want to
when everybody's doing everything I want
to go the opposite direction so I want
to be an old man with beautiful hair
just show up hair dude out of nowhere
I've had hair like this for 30 years and
then I show up with [__] awesome yeah
just silver too now i' I Dy it like a
silver fox I look incredible I look like
wise and hot wise and hot yeah I've got
it all planned out looking good but we
got to wrap it up gang ladies and
gentlemen Mr stavos Halas he want he
said let's do one
more one guy a I think we did two aort a
um I didn't mean to no it's okay now
they're going to suck this yeah now
there's a lot of pressure on me pulling
good
question let's end it I you guys ever
bite your
fingernails nothing uh all right this
one's pretty good this is from Fritz $10
homie never had one read is it garbage
if you knew one of the kids on an
episode is Scared Straight that's so
[__] you're running with a bad crowd
if that's the case they got Ronnie
that's no good absolutely garbage I
remember when that dropped the next day
in school everybody's like did you
[__] and see that was The Realest
[__] anyone's ever seen it's petrifying
my mom always scared me with that stuff
it wasn't it wasn't that but it was
there was a home St gabes that's where
they would send you and they would come
and you keep doing it I'm going to send
you to St gabes and then that she's like
she she used to fake Callin that's that
the guys were coming to get me Jesus
like go upstairs and pack they're coming
they're pack yeah that's [__]
psychological warfare dud why would you
do that to a 9-year-old yeah well it
really worked he didn't he didn't
develop any [__] on the floor problem
yeah scared to death they're going to
take me
away ladies and gentlemen Mr stavos hus
brand new special out on Netflix fat
Rascal do yourself a favor get over and
check it out he is one of the funniest
one of the hardest working one of the
most successful guys working today the
biz one of the best of the biz man we
love you Budd thanks for having me and
of course stav's world stav's world
listen to it uh yeah a year it's been a
year of stav world you guys were the
first first like in the thir you're like
the third episode I think uh come back
we love we'd love to have you in a nice
first batch the of this year's uh but
yeah please listen to the Pod watch the
special everything and thanks for having
me guys you're the best buddy Kippy what
do you got for him guys we're all over
the road still tickets left uh for
coming up for DC and that second show at
the philm and Philly is about to sell
out if it's not already get them
freaking tickets gang we'll see you out
there love you and we'll see you next
week peace